[Musique]
bienvenue non pas sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire mais chez moi et
cela pour la dernière fois j'espère
puisque je retournerai en studio à
partir de demain
en attendant pour faire un premier bilan
de l'épidémie de coronavirus c'est pour
le faire à l'échelle globale
je veux interrogé antoine flahault
j'avais déjà interrogé au début du mois
d'avril
antoine flahault c'est le directeur de
l'institut de santé globale de
l'université de genève il a donc à la
fois la hauteur et l'expérience
antoine flahault bonjour vous êtes
docteur en médecine et en bio
mathématiques épidémiologistes
professeur de santé publique
vous travaillez sur la surveillance
électronique des maladies et sur
l'épidémiologie prévisionnel
alors nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 4
millions cent vingt mille 4 confirmés
280 3000 morts est ce qu'on connaît
beaucoup mieux
le virus oui il ya eu des progrès
absolument phénoménaux sur la
connaissance de cette nouvelle maladie
qui a émergé en janvier en chine et qui
depuis a fait l'objet d'une intense
recherche très supérieures à toutes les
recherches qui n'ont jamais pu être fait
dans le domaine de la de la médecine et
de la santé et donc on en connaît
beaucoup plus sur ce virus coronavirus
qui est totalement nouveau un même si il
a des liens de parenté on va dire avec
le virus du strass il s'en éloigne de
beaucoup de points de vue et il est
aujourd'hui en effet mieux connue même
si comme pour toutes ces nouvelles
maladies
il reste encore des pans entiers de la
connaissance à parfaire en particulier
du recul parce qu'on n'a pas un recul
très long sur ce virus
on ne sait pas par exemple si le concert
une immunité qui va durer très longtemps
une fois qu'on a contracté le virus ou
si ça va durer que quelques semaines ou
quelques mois où on ne sait pas non plus
toutes les mécanismes
physiopathologiques c'est-à-dire qui
entraîne des des maladies liés à ce
virus
on en connaît quelques uns et on en
connaît de nouveau
on sait que le virus attaque les poumons
il donne des syndromes de détresse
respiratoire aiguë qui nécessite la
réanimation assez rarement mais il peut
aussi donner des réactions
immunologiques on en reparlera peut-être
mais c'est des réactions qui ne sont pas
totalement nouvelle
c'est des réactions qui sont connus avec
d'autres types de virus ou d'agents
infectieux
mais qui n'étaient pas connus par
exemple avec le virus du sras ce que
sait-on aujourd'hui du taux de mortalité
sachant que je les dis on en est à 4
millions cent vingt mille cas confirmés
mais mais on les a évidemment pas tous
comptabilisés il ya tous ceux qui sont
asymptomatiques et puis il ya tous ceux
simplement que l'on n'a pas repéré
néanmoins le taux de mortalité on est
capable de de le calculer aujourd'hui
alors le taux de mortalité qui en fait
un des reflets les plus précis de la
sévérité d'une maladie est difficile à
calculer dans une maladie émergente
c'est particulièrement difficile dans la
phase exponentielle de la maladie
émergente parce que quelque part les
morts qui vous sont rapportés
correspondent à ce qu'on appelle une
cohorte ou un groupe de patients qui
sont arrivés à l'hôpital il y a quelques
jours ou semaines mais qui a beaucoup
changé en nombre par rapport à ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui rapportée dans la
veille sanitaire donc si vous ne faites
que la division très grossière du nombre
de morts rapportées par rapport au
nombre de cas rapportés
vous avez un décalage qui va durer tout
au long de cette phase que j'appelle
exponentielle mais maintenant on en est
déjà à la fin de cette vague peut-être
de cette première vague on ne sait pas
encore mais on a donc un recul qui
permet de faire cette division de façon
plus précise d'une part mais on a en
sorte après un deuxième problème quand
vous faites une division il ya
numérateur le nombre de décès puis un
dénominateur le nombre de cas ce que
vous me demandez c'est le taux de
mortalité c'est donc vraiment de diviser
le nombre de décès par le nombre de cas
mais qu'est ce qu'on appelle un cas est
ce qu'un cas c'est juste quelqu'un qui
est arrivé à l'hôpital avec des signes
du coc vide et qui s'est fait tester et
qui est positif mais alors à ce moment
là vous allez diviser
le nombre des décès que par rapport au
nombre de cas sévères suffisamment
sévère pour être venues à l'hôpital
et là vous allez avoir un taux de
mortalité qui va être assez élevé
parfois de facilement plus de 10 ou 15%
si vous dites non ok on va prendre aussi
les cas vus en ville mais alors quelle
est votre stratégie de dépistage vous
comprenez que si on a une stratégie de
dépistage très offensif comme ont eu les
allemands par exemple
alors vous allez avoir un très grand
nombre de cas confirmés bien supérieurs
en nombre à celui des français qui ont
moins dépister ou des italiens ou des
espagnols et donc vous allez avoir un
taux de mortalité qui paraîtra plus
faible en allemagne parce que le nombre
de donateurs les plus importants ils ont
testé plus de gens possible
symptomatique c'est à dire qu'on peu de
symptômes qui sont peut-être jeunes qui
n'ont qu'une forte heureusement avait
une très faible probabilité de mourir
alors pour résoudre un peu ce problème
on a ce qu'on appelle les enquête de
séroprévalence on a fait dans le canton
de genève en suisse
une enquête de séroprévalence qui a
montré que à peu près 10% de la
population du canton de genève étaient
infectées par le virus
ça ici vous avez à ce moment là comme
dénominateur le dénominateur
probablement le plus exact où
l'estimation la plus exacte possible du
dénominateur et après vous allez
rapporté le nombre de décès à cela et là
vous allez obtenir quelque chose qui
sera plus proche de 1% un peu inférieure
à 1%
si je prends un os notre mode de calcul
et puis j'en terminerai ici avec le
l'exercice de calcul statistique qui est
un petit peu long mais qui montre qu
illustre bien quand même la complexité
du problème
une autre façon de d'estimer ce taux qui
se rapproche de celui que je vous ai
donné du canton de genève
c'était le diamond princess vous savez
ce bateau qui a été mis en quarantaine
sur les côtes du japon
le daemon kansas on a pu presque voir
tous les cas donc on a un très bon
dénominateur puisque tout le monde a été
testé ou presque parfois plusieurs fois
et donc on a su qu'avait 712 personnes
qui avaient été contaminées par le virus
certaines étaient symptomatiques
d'autres avec des symptômes légers et
puis certaines ont eu des symptômes
sévères et 13 sont décédées alors si
vous dit
et 13 par 712 ça fait 1 8% c'est plus
élevé que ce que je vous ai dit pour le
canton de genève mais la population la
démographie dans un bateau comme ça de
croisière et plus âgés on a plus de
personnes de plus de 65 ans dont on sait
que la probabilité de décéder plus élevé
donc si on réajuste grosso modo quand on
dit qu'on est un peu au dessous de 1%
ça doit être à peu près la mortalité par
le cos vide ça paraît pas énorme pour
cent vous dire mortalité d'un pour cent
se dit c'est pas énorme mais en réalité
comme la maladie atteint tellement de
gens aujourd'hui la proportion de gens
qui peuvent être infectés dans la
population est très élevé ça rend
aujourd'hui la mortalité par qu'ovide la
plus élevée de toutes les mortalités
dans le monde c'est à dire que vous
pouvez prendre toutes les causes en ce
moment par semaine
il meurt plus de gens parc au vide que
par toute autre cause cancer du sein
cancer du poumon paludisme ou autres
toute autre maladie
donc aujourd'hui la mortalité par
cosider vraiment la cause de mortalité
la plus élevée dans mon cas où la
plupart des contaminations se produirait
dit-on dans des espaces clos
en intérieur donc lors de rencontres
prolonger ce serait beaucoup plus rare à
l'air libre à new york par exemple le
foyer de contamination principal aurait
été le métro est ce que vous le
confirmer est-ce que c'est effectivement
ce que l'on pense aujourd'hui oui
aujourd'hui on pense que les grands
environnements de contamination sont
d'abord le domicile c'est d'abord chez
soi et le transport et en particulier
les transports un peu confiné qui est
suffisamment prolongée et en particulier
sans protection ce sont des endroits où
vous avez quand il sans protection sans
masque de protection
ce sont des endroits où vous avez
beaucoup de difficultés à tenir une
distance sociale et où vous avez une
forte promiscuité le domicile vous
comprenez bien que si vous êtes
continuer à domicile en famille
que veut dire la distance sociale on vit
ensemble on s'embrasse
on partage les mêmes assiettes on
partage les mêmes couvert on a donc
beaucoup beaucoup de raisons de pouvoir
se contaminer si l'un d'entre nous dans
le foyer est contaminée donc oui les
lieux clos son ont été sont des lieux de
130 amis nations les lycées de l'oise
avait un exemple à 44% de la population
pas simplement des élèves d'ailleurs
mais aussi du personnel et des
enseignants avaient été contaminées dans
le lycée de l'oise quand il ya eu ce
foyer en france donc on voit bien que
les lieux en particulier ou sur les
adultes parce que les écoles primaires
ne semble pas être un haut lieu
d'incubation va dire de ce virus
de façon un peu étonnante n'est pas très
facile à comprendre mais il semble en
tout cas que les adultes quand ils sont
en milieu confiné les universités
certainement les lycées et puis le ces
lieux confinés que peut-être que peuvent
représenter parfois le lieu du travail
ou en tout cas le lieu du domicile sont
très clairement des endroits à haut
risque de contamination
donc aujourd'hui nous enregistrons cette
conversation c'est le jour du
déconfinement en france si l'on veut
voir ses amis
mieux vaut les voir en extérieur qu'en
intérieur c'est une oui je pense que
c'est une sage mesure de dire cela je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on est dans ma
proprement reparler mais on est dans ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un sas de
décompression n'est pas encore dans le
thé confinement total
on le voit bien toutes les mesures n'ont
pas été levées on a levé certains freins
on a une telle peur d'une résurgence
d'un rebond que on veut pas lever tous
les freins en même temps et en effet le
virus circule peu dans la population
il y aller on est vraiment au pied de
cette vague qui est passé et qui est
derrière nous et donc c'est le bon
moment pour entreprendre ce
déconfinement mais ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est si évidemment ça va remonter
est ce qu'on veut c'est éviter que les
quelques nouveaux cas qui chaque jour
encore sont comptabilisés ne viennent
pas s'insérer dans ces chaînes de
transmission intrafamiliale
ou de confinement donc c'est vrai que on
a l'impression que sur des terrasses ou
d'en dehors dans la rue c'est vraiment
pas l'endroit où le virus se sent le
mieux pour venir nous contaminer on
reviendra sur / le déconfinement à
proprement parler mais d'abord on avait
remarqué avec le sar ce qu'elle faisait
allusion tout à l'heure que la
contamination s'était effectuée s'était
concentrée sur un certain nombre de
grandes villes chinoises mais aussi sur
singapour sur taïwan sur toronto si je
me souviens bien
on a l'impression avec le coc u19 qui
c'est arrivé quelque chose d'un peu
similaire mais on dit partage d'huile en
fait
en france par exemple on s'aperçoit que
le nombre des décès dus que vides de ces
concentrés sur 10 départements seulement
et que si l'on en prend 16 départements
alors totalité compte moins de dix morts
donc vraiment ce serait resté concentré
là alors à l'échelle d'un département
plus qu'à l'échelle des villes donc en
tache d'huile
oui vous enregistrez d'ailleurs aucun
mort à l'île de la réunion
au jour d'aujourd'hui donc il y à des
régions françaises très très peu touchés
et d'autres beaucoup plus en fait c'est
vrai ce que vous dites et
l'épidémiologie du coc vides partout
dans le monde en iran en italie en corée
en chine même le coc vide n'a pas été en
apd mais il a été en cette petite tache
d'huile qui ne perd colle pas avec le
reste du territoire
et pourquoi c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas encore expliqué et
d'ailleurs votre question est assez
original et assez peu souvent posée en
fait c'est à dire que même les
épidémiologistes utilisent des modèles
mathématiques qui sont tirées de la
grippe
la plupart ont été développés il ya 13
ans pour la pandémie de grippe la
dernière pandémie de grippe et on les
recycle pour le coc vide mais je ne suis
pas totalement sûr qu'il soit très
adapté à d'épidémiologie à la prédiction
en tout cas du coc vite parce que
justement le coville ce nouveau
coronavirus le sar skov 2 il ne se
propage pas comme le virus de la grippe
le virus de la grippe lui se propage en
ap
il se propage de façon extrêmement
homogène sur le territoire et d'ailleurs
vous pouvez regarder le réseau
sentinelles de l'inserm en france
lorsqu'il montre un pic épidémique
vous avez toute la france qui est rouge
toute la france est atteinte
au même moment on a pu regarder qu entre
l'europe et les états unis
le pic de mortalité était à une semaine
près similaire synchrone avec entre les
deux c'est à dire que vous avez au
niveau de l'hémisphère nord une forme de
synchronisation très forte du virus de
la grippe qu'on observe absolument pas
pour secours d'un virus
moi j'ai parlé un moment du boléro de
ravel enfin on a vu chacun des pays
entrés dans la danse symphonie d'une
façon où la cacophonie vous me direz
peut-être mais d'une façon qui a été
séquentiel mais pas d'une façon
synchrone alors sur quelques semaines et
quelques mois mais enfin on n'a pas vu
toute la france rouge comme vous le
dites c'est plutôt le nord-est de la
france le sud ouest étant parfois très
épargné alors pourquoi cela moi j'ai
avance une hypothèse je peux pas dire
encore aujourd'hui que ce soit une
explication et une hypothèse serait que
la proportion da symptomatique ces tas
de gens n'ayant absolument aucun
symptôme mais contaminées par le virus
serait relativement faible peut-être par
exemple si on reprend le lycée de l'oise
dont je parlais tout à l'heure
17% et est asymptomatique et le sont
restés
c'est à dire c'est des gens qui ont été
infectés par le coronavirus et qui n'ont
développé aucun symptôme même pas de
fièvre pas de tout rien et c'était une
proportion de 10 7%
si vous prenez le virus de la grippe
c'est beaucoup plus que 50 % qui sont
asymptomatiques totalement et je pense
que cette différence peut être une des
explications de cette épidémiologie en
en tache d'huile dont vous parliez parce
que si vous n'avez pas beaucoup d'à
symptomatique vous non seulement c'est
pas le territoire à bas bruit
silencieusement comme vous le faites
avec le virus de la grippe le virus de
la grippe se répand probablement pendant
l'automne de façon très silencieuse avec
ces gens asymptomatiques en grande
majorité qui lorsqu'ils développent un
syndrome grippal sont vus par leur
médecin sans engorgement parce qu'on est
au début du processus et donc ça passe
un peu inaperçu d'avoir un syndrome
grippal n'alerte personnes et puis à un
moment tout cela se rentre dans une
symphonie qui elle est synchrone et vous
avez tout le monde tous les instruments
en même temps et vous avez une émergence
qui
voix qui est très bruyante il ya même un
engorgement des hôpitaux au moment du
pic épidémique de grippe saisonnière
mais il est synchrone et là on n'a pas
cette synchronisation parce que on a
peut-être des gens qui sont peu
asymptomatique et qui donc permettre de
repérer à cette fois l'arrivée je dirais
du virus vous allez dire dans la boîte
de nuit à séoul on a pu repérer la
personne d'ailleurs qui était elle même
je crois à symptomatique mais qui a été
à l'origine du virus vous allez pouvoir
voir l'arrivée du virus dans telle école
dans l assemblée nationale dentelle
dentelle groupes de la société ou
congrégations religieuses ou ou
rassemblements religieux etc
donc oui je suis assez d'accord avec
vous c'est une épidémiologie très
particulière j'avance une hypothèse qui
n'est aujourd'hui pas du tout certaine
mais je pense que davantage de travaux
devraient se pencher sur cette question
tout à fait importante pour particuliers
mieux calibrer les modèles de diffusion
de cette maladie et pourquoi est ce que
ça ne toucherai semble-t-il en grande
majorité des hommes à l'exception
peut-être du québec qu'au québec on
remarque que plus de femmes figurent
parmi les cas confirmés à 60% je crois
et même parmi les 17 à 54% des femmes
notamment du personnel soignant
d'ailleurs mais sinon en france
notamment ce sont surtout des hommes
alors pourquoi alors déjà parce que
probablement on a bien protégé nos
personnels soignants je dis ça c'est
assez important en sept
car vous avez tout à fait raison
lorsqu'il ya une très forte probabilité
proportion de femmes dans une maladie
infectieuse respiratoires généralement
la raison est que le personnel soignant
a été mal protégés ça a été le cas du
strass on a tenu
on a tiré les leçons du strass en le
strass était en 2003 c'était aussi un
coronavirus aussi respiratoires et qui
entraînait des pneumonies extrêmement
sévère au début on a été tellement
surpris par le sera ce que les premiers
hôpitaux qui ont eu à prendre en charge
ces cas ne se sont pas suffisamment
équipés ne se sont pas suffisamment
protégés
et puis on a vu du reste à l'occasion du
strass en particulier des études de
singapour montré que les personnels
soignants lorsqu'il mettait des masques
de protection était très
très bien protégés et c'était ça qu'il
fallait faire et après les gens
dansaient et du coup les premiers la
proportion de femmes dans le strass est
beaucoup beaucoup plus importante que
dans le corps nasco vide 19 donc je
pense que dans le cockpit 19 le fait
qu'ils aient moins de femmes est un bon
reflet de la précaution compris les
soignants pour se protéger maintenant
pourquoi ce n'est pas à égalité
c'est quelque chose d'un peu plus
compliqué et difficile à répondre parce
que non seulement les femmes sont plutôt
moins souvent atteintes que des hommes
mais en plus les femmes sont moins de
complications
les hommes être une jeune femme
aujourd'hui vous soustrait pratiquement
du risque de complications en
particulier de complications fatale du
coc vite pas totalement malheureusement
on doit déplorer quelques décès chez des
femmes aussi
mais les femmes semblent très protégé
sans qu'on en sache vraiment la raison
alors il faut savoir que les femmes
vivent plus longtemps que les hommes et
que on a même pu montrer il ya vu des
études qui ont montré un niveau très
très égal de socio culturel et de
travail par exemple comprenait des
bonnes soeurs et des moines de bonnes
soeurs vivent un peu plus longtemps que
les moines donc il semble que le sexe
protège le sexe féminin protègent contre
beaucoup de maladies et visiblement il a
l'air de protéger aussi contre le corps
d'un virus ce qui est une particularité
qui est encore à moins à mon sens
totalement expliquée et les enfants
alors puisque ça créé une grande
polémique en france au moment de la
réouverture des écoles faut-il envoyer
ses enfants à l'école ou pas que sait-on
aujourd'hui du cas des enfants
alors comme vous desservez dans la
polémique mais aussi dans la controverse
scientifique c'est à dire que le cas des
enfants n'est pas totalement clarifiée
aujourd'hui alors ça doit être un peu
pénible à entendre le fait qu'on ait des
les hésitations des départs fois des
retournements quand on est scientifique
mais il faut comprendre que dans ces
maladies tout à fait nouvelle le
chapitre n'est pas écrit et il s'écrit
un peu sous nos yeux et jusqu'à présent
on
on sait qu' il ya une sorte de paradoxe
qu'il faut relever
on sait que les enfants sont moins
souvent atteints dans les statistiques
on voit moins d'enfants que d'adultes de
façon très claire c'est à dire que que
ce soit les données venant de chine où
les données venant d'europe et des états
unis désormais on a beaucoup beaucoup
moins d'enfants parmi l'ensemble des cas
qui nous sont rapportés pour vous dire
pour la grippe plus de 50 % des cas sont
des enfants pour le coc vide c'est pas
du tout le cas ces quelques pourcents
c'est très très très marginale donc
clairement les enfants semblent moins je
dirais pas forcément porteur du virus on
va revenir là dessus mais en tout cas
moins souvent il exprime des signes de
la maladie qui les amène à consulter et
à se faire tester et à se faire repérer
comme porteurs du virus
par ailleurs il ya très peu de mortalité
chez l'enfant
même parmi les cas il ya une très très
faible mortalité
alors pourquoi il ya une controverse
c'est que ça c'est le côté
épidémiologique des choses mais le côté
des virologues des virologues quand il
regarde ce qu'on appelle la charge
virale qui compte nombre de virus dans
un millilitre de sécrétions nasales
il n'a autant chez l'enfant et chez
l'adulte on n'arrive pas à avoir de
différences de charge virale alors que
tout le monde s'était dit pas si les
enfants sont moins certain c'est que
prouvant leur charge virale est plus
faible
déjà c'est pas cela ensuite on voit
qu'il y à des syndromes post infectieux
des maladie de kawasaki on vous avez
peut-être entendu parler de cela parce
que ça a été rapporté en particulier par
les français et puis par les anglais et
puis très récemment également par les
nord américains alors c'est quoi c'est
des syndromes qu'on appelle poste
infectieux c'est connu avec beaucoup de
maladies il ya deux ans et cela avec par
exemple la grippe on sait que la grippe
entraîne des maladies de guillain et
barré
c'est une maladie neurologique qui
ressemble un peu à une poliomyélite
mais qui n'est pas due à un virus qui
est dû à un vraiment un problème
immunologique de la même façon le
syndrome de kawasaki est un syndrome
inflammatoire c'est pas due à un virus
lui même c'est dû à la réaction que
l'organisme provoque contre le virus et
qui dépasse un petit peu son orgueil
l'organisme lui-même pour entraîner des
maladies c'est dommage s'appelle une
balade immunologique y en a d'autres
et qui ne sont pas toujours liés
d'ailleurs à des virus ou à des
infections mais qui peuvent vraiment
être posé des problèmes de santé et en
particulier chez l'enfant
donc c'est maladie de kawasaki ont fait
une vingtaine d'hospitalisations dans
les hôpitaux parisiens un peu plus en
france
mais ce reste des cas très rares
aujourd'hui tout est extrêmement
médiatisé
aujourd'hui tout est extrêmement porté à
la connaissance des chercheurs mais
aussi du public avec difficulté parfois
de mettre un peu de recul derrière cette
information il faut vraiment faire la
différence entre ce qui concerne une
grande partie de la population et ce qui
concerne des cas rares très rares
il y en a toujours existé en médecine
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
maladies rares comme leurs noms
l'indiquent pas les maladies rares s'ils
voulaient regrouper tous elles
deviennent une maladie fréquente si je
puis dire
donc vous avez ce problème là avec le co
vide qui n'est pas quelque chose
d'inattendu
et je pense même qu'on aura probablement
d'autres l'expression clinique qui vont
nous parvenir parce qu'on va découvrir
d'autres formes rares parfois tardive
peut-être de complications du coc vide
en tout cas au jour d'aujourd'hui chez
les enfants l'épidémiologie ne change
pas elle reste extrêmement peu
préoccupante est peu fréquente chez les
enfants d'âge scolaire
je ne dirais pas la même chose
évidemment si vous dites les mineurs
c'est à dire que les adultes qui vont
dans des lycées vont devenir des adultes
sur plan physiopathologiques et vont
avoir les mêmes risques que les jeunes
adultes et donc vont retomber je dirais
les jeunes adultes sont pas très haut
risque on sait que c'est après 50 ans et
même après 70 ans qu'on devient à très
haut risque avec le co vide mais on
devient quand même beaucoup plus porteur
et beaucoup plus diffuseur du virus
quand on est adulte jeunes en
particulier en milieu confiné
si vous ouvrez bien antoine flahault un
petit tour du monde
de la façon dont on a lutté contre cette
épidémie est et comment sont bavardes
hong kong taiwan et singapour que vous
aviez cité en exemple au début du mois
d'avril quand je vous avais interrogé
pour la première fois hong kong alors
que c'est un des endroits où la densité
de population est la plus forte du monde
c'est évidemment en chine ou à côté de
la chine selon selon le choix qu'on en
fera mais c'est seulement quatre morts
quatre morts et 1000 48 cas confirmés ça
semble incroyable comment l'expliquez
vous oui alors hong kong taiwan
singapour
on peut ajouter aussi la corée du sud
sont des endroits qui comme vous le
dites sont très près de la chine le plus
souvent en comprenne et parle le chinois
de la chine continentale pardon ils
comprennent et par le chinois en
particulier ils comprennent aussi les
réseaux informels qui sont des
informations moins formel qui sont
émises de chine et on va dire que depuis
2003 cesse depuis la sphère du strass
c'est petit
en classe mais qui comme vous dites
singapour ses 6 millions cinq cent mille
habitants pas très loin de la suisse qui
en ces 8 8 millions ça semble sonder des
mégapoles qui sont extrêmement alerté
par le risque d'une maladie émergente
venant de chine continentale et qui vont
se préparer depuis donc maintenant plus
de quinze ans à l'hypothèse d'une
émergence épidémique très sérieuse ils
vont avoir des alertes
le maire ce va revenir en corée du sud
par exemple ils vont avoir des alertes
de grippe aviaire
tout cela ne les fait pas du tout
ergoter sur est-ce que c'est des petites
grippe est où est ce que ce sont des
petits virus de rien non ils s'attendent
à une maladie sérieuse qui pourrait
venir impacter très fortement la santé
de leurs populations
il s'entraîne il
construisent des équipements des
infrastructures et ils s'entraînent ils
m'aiment dissimulent des éventuels
émergence de maladie qui ressemble
beaucoup à ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui
et quand ils s'entraînent ils décident
et planifie à l'avance les besoins
qu'ils auront à déployer de grands
d'urgence au cas où quelque chose se
passerait et quand en début janvier vous
savez le 31 décembre
la chine a notifié officiellement à l'om
est-ce l'existence d'un foyer sans avoir
la certitude distille que la
transmission est interhumaine en disant
que c'est quelque chose qui pour
l'instant il n'a pas encore que cet lié
à coronavirus ils disent que c'est des
pneumonies un foyer johnny et bien dès
le lendemain
les autorités de singapour de hong kong
vont réagir et vont se mettre sur le qui
vive et vont déclencher leurs plans
qu'ils avaient prévu à l'avant ce nom
qui ne vont pas attendre du tout il n'y
aura aucune discussion et tout le monde
suit c'est à dire que quand vous avez
des experts qui se battent qui qui ne
sont pas d'accord
les journalistes évidemment relaie cette
information là le jeu tire elle le
citoyen spectateurs ou lecteur est
partagée évidemment comment voulez vous
que les politiques prennent des
décisions rapides et efficaces à ce
moment là comment voulez vous qu'ils
commandent des tonnes de masques ou des
tout le monde dirait mes cd cd fonds
perdus il faut mieux je suis pas
soutenir l'hôpital public ou autre chose
il n'y avait pas un consensus
derrière une action urgente imminente à
prendre consensus qui existe dans ces
petites démocratie ou pas si petit la
corée du sud ces 50 millions d'habitants
et donc c'est un pays qui finalement est
pas très loin de la france il va
immédiatement réagir se prépare et
mettre en ordre de bataille son pays
pour pouvoir fabriquer le nombre de
tests qu'il faudra pour pouvoir aller
tester les gens pour aller tracé aussi
les contacts etc
je veux simplement on fait une pause on
se retrouve juste après
antoine flahault
[Musique]
nous continuons notre tour du monde du
conte à virus ont fait un premier bilan
avec antoine flahault le diet le
directeur de l'institut de santé globale
de l'université de genève
je reviens sur hong kong taiwan et
singapour hong kong
ces quatre morts sur 1048 de cas
confirmés je prends des chiffres du jour
taiwan cette mort sur 440 cas confirmés
à moins que ce soit 1440 dans ces 440 et
singapour ses vingt morts sur 23 1822
cas confirmés
les masques vous en avez parlé on
consent bien que il ya chez les
asiatiques et notamment hong kong une
culture du masque qui n'existent pas du
tout en france on voit bien que les
français sont totalement malhabile
maladroit avec leurs masques ils ne
cessent de l'est de les toucher
alors qu'ils font justement pas toucher
la surface extérieure puisque c'est là
où sont censés se colmater les
gouttelettes que nous envoie les
passants en tout cas ce que nous
croisons ça risque d'être un problème en
france avec le déconfinement ce mauvais
usage cette mauvaise connaissance des
bases oui et non je pense qu'il faut
voir plutôt les progrès qui ont été
faits dans les cultures occidentales
pour l'utilisation du masque vous pouvez
plus aujourd'hui en pleine période de
déconfinement vous balader dans la rue
sans voir une proportion qui doit être
différente à genève à paris ou à berlin
mais il ya une proportion de gens qui
mettent des masques je pense que on ne
change pas sa culture du jour au
lendemain mais quand même on voit qu'on
s'adapte très vite je me souviens ça n'a
vraiment rien à voir mais ça l'analogie
émergent ma conscience c'est que
lorsqu'il ya eu la pandémie de sida etc
on s'était aperçu que l'afrique était
extrêmement touché beaucoup de gens
avaient des préjugés disait en afrique
ils mettront pas de préservatif c'est
pas possible c'est pas leur culture
et puis quand les gens ont vu qu'il y
avait des gens qui mouraient dans leurs
proches dans leur famille etc et bien
bien entendu ils ont été comme tout le
monde que nous sommes tous quoi ils ont
été conscients
du problème du risque et ils se sont mis
à mettre des préservatifs la même façon
je pense que le mas qui est en train de
devenir un des moyens de protection
les personnels de santé vous savez au
début les occidentaux dans les hôpitaux
occidentaux ce n'était pas si facile de
faire porter un masque c'est pas très
agréable de travailler avec leurs
masques en plus les personnels et santé
ont parfois des masses qu'on appelle
ffp2 qui sont des masques qui protège
encore plus en particulier quand les
gouttelettes d'aérosols sont sont très
fines dans après certaines procédures
invasives en médecine et bien c'est
difficile c'est une masse très
hermétique ce n'est pas très agréable de
travailler avec cela et bien les
personnalisant télémètre remarquablement
bien dans les hôpitaux et d'ailleurs il
ya assez peu de personnels de santé qui
ont été contaminés donc je pense que le
masque a prouvé son efficacité de façon
extrêmement emblématique et que face à
cela tout dépend de la perception que
l'on a du risque c'est vrai que quand on
est dans une telle décrue que très peu
de cas surviennent le masque
probablement les gens tombent le masque
si je puis dire et le mettent moins sur
moi inconscient etc
et dès que l'on verra que le virus
circule à nouveau et qu'on verra une
nouvelle ré émergence du virus ce que
j'espère nous reverrons pas mais si
jamais de des foyers survenait dans tel
ou tel endroit
je suis assez intimement persuadé que
les gens remettrait des masques la chose
que vous dites
en revanche est crucial c'est qu' il
vaut mieux ne pas mettre de masques du
tout que de mettre un masque en base est
tous sous son nez on voit beaucoup
beaucoup trop de gens parce que pour
pour quelles raisons c'est pas parce
qu'ils c'est pas parce qu'il se comporte
mal c'est simplement parce qu'ils n'en
n'ont pas peut-être pu l'enseignement la
formation je veux dire les personnes de
santé on les forme à mettre des masques
et on s'auto redresse entre nous en
disant mais attends ton basque en train
de glisser là vous voulez fait mais une
cigarette
vous allez enlever votre base
complètement vous allez vous nettoyer
les mains et vous aller fumer votre
cigarette ou vap eva poté votre
cigarette électronique voulez boire un
verre dans un bar à lait n'est n'y
allait pas avec un mal ce que ça n'a pas
de sens vous n'avez pas le mettre en
bavent est en effet vous mettez en un
peu au-dessous du nez à masquer ce comme
vous dites ce se connecte toutes les
gouttelettes de postillons qui vous sont
émises de droite et de gauche par des
gens qui sont potentiellement porteurs
du virus
si jamais il ya un porteur du virus ça
aura bloqué tant que le masque sera bien
mis sur votre nez et votre bouche sera
bloqué l'ensemble de ces gouttelettes
qui n'arriveront pas à vos voies
respiratoires et d'un coup vous allez
les proposer à vos voisins aérienne
respiratoire que vous allez inspirer de
façon quasi expérimental il n'y a pas
d'heure d'infection plus expérimental
que cela et là il aurait mieux valu
tomber le masque complètement
donc je dirais ne mettez pas de masque
si vous le mettez mal et si vous mettez
bien le masque il vous protégera presque
à coup sûr en corée du sud ses 256 morts
seulement sur 10 1909 4 confirmer
l'épidémie cendres et réguler mais séoul
a ordonné la fermeture des bars et des
discothèques en raison de l'apparition
de nouveaux foyers de contamination il
ya de quoi s'inquiéter
je crois que la dernière fois quand on
s'était parlé on s'est dédit est ce
qu'il y aura une déco déconfinement en
stop and go
je pense que aujourd'hui on est dans ce
sas de déconfinement qui nous quitte une
forme d'expérimentation de ce que l'on
peut faire et jusqu'où on va voir s'il y
a un effet rebond
je considère pas que le fait qu'il y ait
un foyer par ci un foyer par là si vous
regardez les courbes de corée du sud
elles sont magnifiques je veux dire la
vague complètement derrière eux alors
qu'il y ait une résurgence avec quelques
centaines de cas c'est même moins de ci
de là c'est quelque chose qui risque
d'arriver
tant que l'on n'aura pas trouvé de
vaccin contre cette maladie
donc pour le moment c'est pas une grande
source de préoccupation qu'il se trouve
des foyers de résurgence de ci de là
d'autant plus quand c'est une chez des
gens jeunes en bonne santé dont on sait
que le risque de complications est très
très très faible
rappelez-vous que sur le charles de
gaulle où il ya eu une épidémie qu'on
aurait probablement pu éviter il ya eu
aucun décès à déplorer
je veux dire quand on a affaire à des
gens jeunes on a fort heureusement une
très bonne résilience sanitaires
maintenant je crains qu'en effet on est
et que l'on voit des petits rebonds de
ce genre parce que on va lever des
freins à ceux à cette épidémie à cette
dynamique épidémique et que probablement
on verra certain rebond ce qu'il faut
juste c'est que le contrôle soit
suffisant pour qu'on ne vienne pas
réengager les hôpitaux de l'objectif du
confinement n'était pas de faire
disparaître la pandémie personne n'avait
vraiment ce rêve qu'on pourrait tout
savoir mais personne ne pensait que le
confinement permettrait d'éradication du
virus en revanche il permet d'éviter
l'engorgement des hôpitaux et
aujourd'hui la corée n'a pas du tout
n'est pas dans la crainte d'un
engorgement des hôpitaux mais les en
stop and go elle se dit peut-être que
ces boîtes de nuit sont justement ces
vases clos dont on parlait au début de
notre entretien où se diffuse très
particulièrement bien ce virus avant de
faire un bilan du confinement du grand
confident ce sont comme ça qu'on
l'appellera dans les livres d'histoire
parlant de la suède qui n'a pas confiné
et qui affiche aujourd'hui 3225 mort sur
200 soit sur 26 1322 cas confirmés elle
a cherché l'immunité collective
quel bilan peut-on faire aujourd'hui de
l'expérience suédoise alors je pense que
c'est un peu tôt aujourd'hui pour faire
le bilan de l'expérience suédoise devant
plus que je dirais les suédois demande
qu'on fasse ce bilan une fois que
l'épidémie où la pandémie sera terminée
dans sont les suédois ont une stratégie
qui est en effet très très très
différente de tous les autres on a passé
un petit peu en revue dans ce petit tour
du monde les démocraties asiatiques
on avait parlé à notre dernière émission
du cas de la chine
et d'ailleurs de sa son introduction
d'un confinement strict qui a été repris
par les français par les espagnols par
les italiens et puis par la moitié du
monde
les démocraties asiatiques ont peut-être
inspirer davantage l'allemagne la suisse
mais nous avons tous confinés notre
économie et notre vie sociale
les suédois eux un peu à l'exemple des
démocraties et d'ailleurs dont on a
parlé c'est à dire hong kong singapour
pendant longtemps n'a pas confiné non
pas confiner leurs économies la suède
n'a pas confiné son économie elle a en
effet laissé bars et restaurants ouverts
commerce non essentiels ouverts etc
et elle a un bilan aujourd'hui
sanitaires qui se situe à mi chemin
entre la suisse et la france
vous savez si on regarde la mortalité
par million d'habitants qui est
peut-être un assez bon critère on voit
que l'autriche en europe est le meilleur
élève que l'allemagne se situent juste
après et qu'après il ya la suisse la
suède la france l'italie l'espagne
si vous vous dites on est sans avoir
confiné son économie à mi chemin entre
la suisse et la france
vous pouvez vous dire presque c'est déjà
un bon bilan puisque finalement au moins
l'économie fonctionne bien ce qu'il faut
ce dire quand même c'est que ce serait
caricatural de penser que la suède n'a
pas du tout confiné son économie ni sont
sont sa vie sociale en réalité par
exemple les suédois au moment du
week-end de pâques avaient le droit
inaliénable de prendre leur voiture et
d'aller sur la côte ouest
or 90 % des routes suédoises étaient
enfin le trafic a diminué de 90% pendant
le week-end de pâques par rapport au
week-end de pâques des années
précédentes donc les suédois se sont
auto confiné ils ont eu des messages de
la part des agences sanitaires qui leur
disaient restez chez vous exactement
comme en france simplement ça n'est pas
la loi qui leur à leur a demandé il
n'avait pas le droit de se rassembler à
plus de 50 personnes
figurez vous que les autorités de police
lorsqu'ils voyaient des rassemblements
de plus de 50 personnes dans la
une manifestation par exemple ils
n'avaient pas la possibilité de
verbaliser donc les suédois c'est très
participative c'est un pays où on a
l'habitude d'abord on a une très
profonde culture de santé publique
les indicateurs de santé sont
exceptionnelles en suède la suède est un
pays qui sait ce qu'est la prévention
pour vous dire la suède n'est pas un
pays soviétiques ou post soviétique
et pourtant le l'alcool n'est pas en
vente libre en suède il est dans des
magasins d'état non non c'est à dire
qu'ils ont voté eux mêmes pour que l'on
réguler leur vente d'alcool pour qu'ils
aient moins envie d'en acheter parce que
les magasins sont un peu tristes et
haineuse et sont fermés sont ouverts aux
heures d'ouvertures des des services
publics étant fermés de skf alors
ailleurs donc maintenant en france en
particulier on a choisi le confinement
strict
est ce qu'on a bien fait parce que vous
l'aviez dans les précédentes éditions le
confinement
c'est tout ce qu'on a 100 ans de retard
en choisissant de confinement par
rapport aux démocraties asiatiques
on aurait pu ne pas le faire parce que
l'allemagne et la truffe l'autriche ont
opéré différemment
quel bilan on peut faire aujourd'hui de
cette expérience encore une forme là
suffisamment d'idées dit et dont on ne
mesure pas encore aujourd'hui toutes les
conséquences sur le plan économique sur
le plan social ce que ça va donner mais
c'est un autre débat celui ci sur le
plan sanitaire
est ce qu'on a bien fait oui vous avez
raison d'essayer de cerner parce que
sinon ça rend la réponse extrêmement
complexe alors sur le plan sanitaire
ce que l'on peut dire c'est que les
mesures du confinement
c'est le confinement ça vise à réduire
le nombre de contacts que l'on a avec
les autres
on s'est aperçus ces d'épidémiologie
théorique qui nous donne ces règles là
que dans le fond la transmissibilité
c'est leur taux de reproduction de
l'épidémie il est
j'irai le produit d'une probabilité de
transmission que l'on peut baisser en
mettant des masques de protection et
d'un nombre de contacts
quand on dit nombre de contacts c'est
pas tous les contacts ces les contacts
plutôt en milieu clos qui ont qui dure
plutôt plus d'un quart d'heure et à une
distance de moins de deux mètres
évidemment sans ce masque de protection
si vous avez des contacts comme ça et
bien plus vous les réduisent et ce
nombre de contacts et quand y'a aucun
confinement entre 20 et 25 en moyenne
par français si vous pouvez évidemment
il ya des gens qui ont beaucoup plus
aidé j'entends beaucoup moins mais si
vous réduisez en moyenne ce nombre de
contacts de façon assez drastiques
vous avez réduire la transmissibilité du
virus et vous aller opérer ce qu'on a vu
sur les courbes épidémique c'est à dire
une cassure de la coop une réalisation
presque complète de l'épidémie c'est
quelque chose qui a été obtenu grâce au
confinement
donc là la première réponse est oui le
confinement a été sans doute un grand
succès en matière sanitaire parce qu'il
a permis de faire exactement ce que l'on
voulait faire c'est-à-dire aplatir la
courbe épidémique et éviter
l'engorgement des hôpitaux
mission réussie maintenant la question
que vous me posez elle est presque à
deux étages est ce que le confinement
strict à la chinoise où je veux dire à
la française c'est à dire l'assignation
à résidence était d'une valeur ajoutée
en matière d'efficacité par rapport à un
confinement plus libéral que nous avons
connue en suisse en allemagne en
autriche aux pays bas il ya un la
réponse là est beaucoup plus mitigé
il ya des études qui ont été faites là
dessus et qui ne montre pas de vraie
valeur ajoutée significative du
confinement strict par rapport au
confinement au semis confinement que
nous avons connues je mettrai un bémol
vous parliez de culture tout à l'heure
dans le fond je vous ai donné plutôt des
cultures nordiques par exemple
d'ailleurs en suisse on voit très bien
la différence de mortalité qui est bien
inférieur en suisse alémanique par
rapport à la suisse italienne et la
suisse romande
donc il semblerait quand même qu'il y
ait aussi une sorte de civisme d'esprit
citoyen plus compliants à l'auto
confinement dans des cultures nordiques
et peut-être germanique que dans les
cultures latines qu'on a vu dans le sud
de l'europe
donc il est possible que on est le
confinement qu'on mérite
si je puis dire c'est un peu peut-être
un peu simpliste peut être ça mérite
davantage d'études anthropologiques pour
avant de conclure de façon certaine
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de valeur
ajoutée très nette qui se dessine du
confinement strict lorsque je pense on
est capable d'un auto confinement je
dirais participatif et citoyens comment
expliquez-vous antoine flahault les bons
chiffres de l'allemagne de l'autriche la
suisse pas seulement parce qu'ils sont
tellement qu'ils sont de culture
allemande
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence alors
beaucoup glosé sur sur les différences
car elles sont patentes il ya des
différences très clair qui sont presque
de 1 à 4 en matière de mortalité absolue
entre eux le l'allemagne et la france
est même supérieure en terme de
différence absolue entre l'autriche et
la france donc l'allemagne a été
beaucoup plus performante dans sa
réponse que la france l'espagne ou
l'italie
quelles sont les raisons alors il ya
plusieurs raisons possibles il ya des
gens qui disent mais simplement par le
fait du hasard les foyers puisque vous
disiez c'est plutôt le nord-est de la
france si la france n'avait été que le
sud ouest on aurait été encore meilleur
en fait c'est donc il est vrai qu'il est
possible qu'ils aient un effet un peu de
hasard que des clusters était moins fort
en allemagne en autriche en suisse que
en france en italie en espagne
moi j'y vois une autre raison qui reste
évidemment à confirmer qui est la
politique de testing de test de ces
fameux tests pcr qui permettent de dire
vous êtes porteur du virus
pour vous dire quand les les chiffres
changent tout le temps mais quand les
allemands avaient fait plus de deux
millions de tests les français en est
ailleurs
or à 450 me c'est presque d'ailleurs
cette différence de 1 à 4 dont je
parlais si vous testez vous allez bien
mais parce que vous testez quelqu'un
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça ça ne
guérit pas un malade du coc vide je vais
pas moins mourir parce que vous me
tester bien sûr je suis d'accord mais si
vous me tester si si je vous teste et
que vous vous savez que vous êtes vous
venez vous avez une petite tout un
quelque chose de très grave
vous avez une petite toux et vous venez
pour vous faire tester dans un pays on
vous teste dans l'autre on vous dit vous
rentrez chez vous vous avez pas vous
revenez pas d'un pays d'endémie on va
pas vous tester dans l'autre vous teste
on vous teste et on dit désolé monsieur
taddei vous êtes porteur du virus
ça va durer si vous avez tellement peu
de symptômes que vous allez le reste est
porteur cinq ou six jours mais on vous
propose tout allait dans un hôtel de
confinement tout seul
vraiment vous n'allez pas être en
contact avec vos proches ou alors si
vous avez la possibilité de rester chez
vous bien calfeutré et que personne ne
vous ne vous approche de trop près sans
protection
alors c'est possible si on vous dit cela
est-ce que franchement vous pensez pas
que vous même vous allez faire très
attention que chez vous conservez un peu
comme un pestiféré pendant quelques
jours on n'aura pas envie de vous
approcher voudrais pas très appétissant
bref on va s'auto confiné de façon
beaucoup beaucoup plus efficace si l'on
est dans la connaissance que l'on est
porteur du virus que si on n'est pas
dans cette connaissance et je pense que
on a négligé beaucoup trop l'impact
qu'avait la valeur du test sur la
vraiment la fracture des chaînes de
transmission
on a réussi à rompre en allemagne en
autriche en suisse beaucoup plus de
chaînes de transmission qu'on a réussi à
le faire en france jusqu'à présent je
pense que la leçon a été retenue et
qu'on a entendu des autorités françaises
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup plus pro
actif pour mettre en oeuvre à la fois ce
dépistage ce cette identification des
porteurs du virus mais aussi le fait de
tracer des contacts et d'isoler des gens
qui sont porteurs du virus des gens qui
sont bien portants le cas des états unis
quatre-vingt mille cinq cent soixante
quatorze morts aujourd'hui sur un
million trois cent soixante mille cas
confirmés qu'est ce qu'on peut dire des
états unis alors c'est une tragédie aux
états unis qui nous fait dire que pour
lutter contre le corps d'un virus
il n'y a pas seulement le test il n'ya
pas seulement la qualité des hôpitaux
il y a également la qualité du système
de protection sociale on est en train de
découvrir avec cette maladie que les
gens qui sont vulnérables dans la
société parce qu'ils ne sont pas bien
assuré social qu'est ce qu'ils font et
bien déjà quand ils ont des symptômes
ils les cachent pas ce qu'ils veulent
aller travailler parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de compensation il n'y a pas d'arrêt
maladie
il n'y a pas de quand vous êtes dans des
états très libéraux qui ont négligé
beaucoup le la protection sociale vous
avez des réflexes qui vont et des
réflexes qui vont tendre à diffuser
l'épidémie ça c'est une première chose
puis après si vous êtes malade et bien
vous n'aurez pas les moyens vous n'allez
pas vous ruiner pour vous soigner parce
que vous avez votre famille à nourrir et
donc vous n'aurez pas les moyens de vous
traiter et si vous n'avez pas les moyens
de vous traitez vous allez retarder le
plus possible jusqu'à ce que vous soyez
dans un état tellement grave qu'il
finisse par vous m en réanimation parce
qu'on est quand même dans un pays où il
ya un secteur hospitalier un secteur de
santé très performant on va vous mettre
mettre souvent trop tard et on
n'arrivera pas à vous à vous sauver
c'est que c'est comme ça qu'on a vu une
épidémiologie très particulière en
amérique avec beaucoup de noirs
américains ou de d'hispaniques dont des
conditions socio social économique était
extrêmement défavorisés veut dire ans
les le nombre des cas on a vu cela à
singapour vous savez à singapour tout
s'était très bien passé avec les
magnifiques technique de testing de
trafic de driving etc
et puis début avril il ya eu une
explosion de cas dans des cités dortoirs
de travailleurs immigrés dans des
conditions de promiscuité très précaire
avec des conditions sanitaires aussi
précaire
et singapour a eu à faire face à quelque
chose qui l avait un peu ignorée elle
avait comme on a tous dans nos pays
un très haut niveau de vie nos j'irai
poches de vulnérabilité que l'on
entretient et pour lequel on ferme un
peu les yeux on a vu en france dans le
neuf et 3 aussi des difficultés
d'observer le confinement on a vu des
dégâts plus importants dans dans le dans
ce département du nord de paris où aussi
on voit n'ont peut-être pas une extrême
vulnérabilité et d'absence de protection
sociale comme il ya aux états unis c'est
pas ça que je veux dire mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que on est en train de
voir dans différents endroits du monde
on pourra reparler de mayotte aussi des
endroits où la vulnérabilité n'êtes pas
loin de là la lutte contre cette
épidémie
dans le cas du 93 l'est de la
seine-saint-denis on observe aussi que
c'est là que sont généralement les
kabyles que les gens qui ne sont pas
confinés qui vont travailler les aides
soignants les questions sur tout à fait
les policiers les agents de sécurité on
observe aussi que c'est là qu'il ya
beaucoup de cas d'obésité notamment de
diabète de par la consommation la
nourriture qui est content qu'ils aient
consommé
ceci explique aussi peut-être cela oui
il ya une sorte de de cercle vicieux qui
cumule toutes les facteurs de risque à
la fois d'acquisition de diffusion dans
le reste de la communauté et de sévérité
et de complications
donc je pense que c'est des alertes très
très importante à savoir parce que ça
risque d'être en fait le talon d'achille
y compris des pays les plus riches de la
planète alors terminons notre tour du
monde il nous reste quelques minutes
l'afrique
qu'est ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui
alors l'afrique semble être dans un
paradoxe ceci qui est un paradoxe
favorable puisque aujourd'hui on ne voit
pas d'hécatombe annoncé par certains
pour l'afrique l'afrique nous
préoccupaient beaucoup parce qu'elle
cumule un certain nombre de ces
problèmes de vulnérabilité d'absence de
protection sociale dont nous avons parlé
mais aussi d'infrastructures sanitaires
moi je me disais vous avez quand on
voyait qu en france la moitié des gens
en réanimation avait moins de 55 ans on
pouvait se dire mais dans le fond tous
ces jeunes qui sont en réanimation en
france ils sont sauvés grâce à
l'infrastructure sanitaire
c'est pas que le coc vide n'est pas
grave chez les jeunes c'est que quand
vous êtes jeune et que vous pouvez
bénéficier d'une infrastructure
sanitaire adéquat
alors vous êtes sauvés c'est un peu
différente et je me disais en afrique le
problème où il ya régné un ventilateur
tous les tous les millions d'habitants
vous avez une très grande difficulté
peut-être de vous dire que vous allez
sauver une grande partie de la
population qui pourraient être atteintes
est de cette façon là c'est pas ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui semble-t-il
l'afrique paraît en partie épargnée par
le virus et ses complications la
démographie peut l'aider parce qu'on
essaye à beaucoup de jeunes mais voyez
mayotte est un département où la moitié
de ses habitants aux moins de 18 ans le
département français où la moitié de ses
habitants à moins de 18 ans et mayotte
et pourtant bayonne
en train de connaître une épidémie très
féroce en ce moment donc la mortalité
reste faible en particulier sans doute
parce que la population est jeune mais
la situation est préoccupante et ce qui
est préoccupant c'est certainement
mayotte mais mayotte va bénéficier
on pense tous de l'infrastructure
sanitaire des départements français et
de l'aide française
mais ce qui préoccupe ans et que mayotte
est une des quatre comores initialement
géographiquement et donc c'est
probablement le signe que les comores
qui font partie de la région afrique ce
sont très touchées également et on ne le
sait pas donc il est aussi possible que
les statistiques qui nous parviennent
d'afrique soit très imparfaite est très
incomplète
est-ce qu'on peut encore espérer que le
que l'été kühl virus moi j'ai beaucoup
pour espérer cela et je continue à
l'espérer pour vous dire il ya deux
conditions pour que les têtus le virus
comme vous dites c'est que pour que le
virus soit un virus saisonnier dans les
zones tempérées de l'hémisphère nord de
l'hémisphère sud
il faut que dans l'hémisphère nord à
partir de la mi du milieu du mois de
juin
on ne voit plus de circulation du virus
est que dans l'hémisphère sud commence
dès épidémies
alors ce qui est vrai c'est que on
commence à voir des épidémies qui
émergent en afrique du sud en chili en
particulier en argentine
on ne se réjouit pas pour eux
l'hémisphère sud pourrait connaître à ce
moment-là d épidémie sévère maintenant
ce qui n'est pas très convaincant
aujourd'hui c'est que dans l'hémisphère
nord
si vous regardez par exemple la russie
vous voyez que ça flambe donc on est
quand même milieu du mois de mai donc je
suis pas du tout certain que l'hypothèse
d'un frein estivale très fort soit celle
qui soit aujourd'hui la plus probable
il est possible aussi que le frein soit
partiel on dit que je suis pas si j'ai
le temps de faire ce petit développement
mais on dit que le frein estivale agi à
60% sur le facteur de transmissibilité
qu'on appelle le taux de reproduction
pour la grippe mais la grippe a un taux
de reproduction le fameux air 0 qui est
de 1.5 une personne transmet à une
personne et demi la grippe quand il a la
grippe
alors que si vous faites 60% de 1.5 vous
tomber au dessous de 1
et vous contrôlez il ya jamais
d'épidémie de grippe pendant les
périodes estivales dans l'hémisphère
nord
mais si vous prenez le même type de
freinage que la grippe et que vous
l'appliquez ou coronavirus dont le r0 et
de trois ou de quatre tombait jamais au
dessous de 1
et vous avez toujours des épidémies à
risque donc il est possible qu'on ait au
moins peut-être pas un répit estival
mais qu'on est un peu d' aide de la part
de la saison estivale pour nous aider
dans le déconfinement et pour nous
permettre d'aller à la plage et de nous
embrasser à nouveau et d'aller dans des
bars mais il n'est pas totalement sûr
que cela nous permette d'éviter toute
épidémie mme toute résurgence épidémie
dernière question on n'a que deux
victoires en deux minutes pour y
répondre
antoine flahault on est tous aujourd'hui
à ceux demandés y aura-t-il une deuxième
vague est ce que ça va repartir
peut-être même devra-t-on nous re
confiné alors à quoi êtes vous attentif
vous aujourd'hui
oui tous plaident pour qu'il y ait
malheureusement des vagues successives
peut être une deuxième peut-être même
plus parce que on voit pas pourquoi on
se débarrasserait de ce virus comme ça
on est pas de vin c'est le sras avait
disparu comme il était arrivé donc je
pense qu'il faut être extrêmement
attentif au nombre de nouveaux cas ce
fameux r0 transfert effectif ce nombre
de reproduction essayer de le maintenir
au dessous de 1
et puis surtout à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
un ré engorgement des hôpitaux et qu'on
ne soit toujours dans une bonne marge de
sécurité pour que le système de santé
fonctionne correctement tout en or qu'on
finance surtout pas le pays je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce que l'on veut c'est ne
pas retomber dans des confinement qui
paralyse la vie économique et sociale du
pays mais que l'on puisse vivre avec
je ne sais pas pendant combien de temps
et vivre le plus normalement possible
avec ce virus merci beaucoup antoine
flahault
et peut être qu'on fera si notre
émission ensemble à la toute fin
et là on pourra faire un
bilan général est totale de cette
épidémie
merci et à bientôt merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]